decorating people the river of peoples
kind of down to Trickle
so my role is our next speaker and um
go ahead the next hour is all yours
yeah thank you very much for the
invitation uh to this workshop and for
the opportunity of speaking here very
much enjoying it uh I'm sorry that I'm
going to be there in person
um so I have a couple of quick
announcements uh
uh first of all
um 15 years ago I wrote a survey on
collision bounds for polynomials I've
just revised it
just a few months ago so if you want to
have a kind of like an organic uniform
Viewpoint rendering of this material uh
maybe you you you you can check it it's
on my webpage uh the second is the
second thing is that I'm currently
spending time writing a book completion
complexity is being serialized on my
blog uh and any government will be very
welcome
okay
so
um this is a possible view of complexity
Theory uh it looks like a pyramid at the
top we have you know uh the prss MP
problem and at the base of the pyramid
you have a bunch of you know very
interesting but somewhat specialized
problems like circuits involving
circuits communication rigidity
polynomials and so forth and
go ahead
no I have a editorial P naught equal MP
is not the top of the pyramid it's much
it's down near the base okay okay and
after that we have we start doing
computation complexity after we show P90
yeah thank you yes yes uh yeah okay uh
okay so
um
yeah
uh yeah okay
um I'm going to propose a different view
um that the pyramid is maybe upside down
uh so plus SMP is still at the top okay
there's gonna be something more after
that but for now I'm just gonna focus on
on this and that should there aren't
really there are many problems here
there's maybe only a few problems there
may be only a handful at the tip and
um at the at the base of the the pyramid
that we really have to understand to
make progress and a good question is
what goes uh in here okay so to answer
this question I'm now I'm going to now
um consider a few different problems uh
well-known uh Frontier problems in
complexity
okay
um so one problem is the approving
circuit lower bounds okay I'm not gonna
Define it more formally now
another problem is to exhibit medicines
which are rigid this is something which
was proposed by Valiant in the 70s and
it means cup with medicines which are
far in Heming distance from low rank
medicines okay so Matrix which you know
uh you have to change many entries to
get the low rank Matrix okay
um another question is correlation
bounds for polynomials so this means
giving
exhibiting functions which are very hard
to compute on average they don't
correlate with polynomials I'm going to
Define formally some of these boxes in
just a bit but for now I'm focusing on
the big picture okay and another
question is multivarity communication
complexity this especially in the number
on forehead more that is fascinating
setting by Chandra force and Lipton in
there is
and here we are stuck at the login
players uh as as is well known
um so these are all long-standing
problems and I'm going to put some
arrows now so I'm going to put the
narrow from A to B uh if progress on a
requires progress on B okay so one arrow
is here it's from circuit lower bounds
to correlation bounce for polynomials so
what does this mean if you want to prove
strong circular bounds you actually have
to prove correlation bounds for
polynomials why is that so I'm just
going to say it in in Awards right
because if you if you have a function f
and for every distribution so here
regulation bounce I mean uh for any
distribution so if for every
distribution I can exhibit the
polynomial which has some good enough
correlation then I can use the standard
the min max LP Duality how you want to
call it argument to
um compute this function in the worst
case okay but some majority of
polynomials which you can write as a
small circuit okay depending on the
parameters of the circuit it could have
quasi polynomial size or you can be more
precise about this partial the problem
I'm not going to get into that now let's
just say quasi Poland size circuits okay
so if you want to prove supercoism super
question
lower bounds even for the three then you
gotta prove this this correlation
balance for for problems and I'm going
to Define exactly the collection balance
in in just a few slides this is well
known perhaps something which is maybe a
little bit less well known is that even
metric siligured implies correlation
bounds for for polynomials and here the
catch is is that even if you want the
constant
constant uh relative error in Matrix uh
rigidity you must prove a very strong
average case harder than four polymer so
you you you you go to like you know uh
constant error here to like half minus
little 100 yes you can sort of like
boost
so in the setting of valiant for example
in which you just want some consonant
error you must prove first
um very strong Collision balance for
polynomials
and you may have guessed now that you
also an arrow from here is also is maybe
not
too well known and here again the catch
is that even if you want to prove a
worst case lower bounds for multivarity
communication complexity for more than
login players okay so breaking this
long-standing uh login barrier for
multi-artic communication complexity
number for a protocol even in the worst
case you must prove a correlation
balance like average case harder for
polynomials
okay and there's more so I'm going to
discuss Trader one more error which is
more recent
um and recently there's been some
proposals of some Fourier conjectures
for four polynomials and
um it was not clear that these things
require the correlation bounce but uh
you know it was shown that even those
required correlation models and I will I
will say more about
this Celestia okay so given this I'm
going to propose
this picture here
okay that maybe uh this problem is
there was a little bit of of uh of
effort and you know I don't know that
they they're necessary for every long
selling problem complexity of course but
I don't know of a problem and maybe you
know and I'll be curious to you know
that I don't know about the problem that
you know it's required for it's for such
a a variety of long-standing questions
in in complexity Theory okay
um so I'm going to now formally Define
this correlation bound so for
polynomials and again if you want to
have you know uh some again even you can
look at my survey
so I'm just to be precise now so the
challenge here is to exhibit a function
let's say on M bits a Boolean function
and some distribution X
on the input such that for every
polynomial P of degree d
okay
the correlation between F and P is small
so the correlation is just a defense
limit for the probability that f of x is
is equal to P of X well X is drawn from
our distribution okay and should be at
most half plus episode you can always
get off by just by random guessing and
this is half precepts
so what do we know there's two very well
known bounds then I'm going to uh
discuss again for background so India
this raspberry and smallest
proved in particular this bound the
derivative actually is from smonesky's
paper but raspberry proves something
similar for other symmetric functions
yeah I think I know the answer but I
just want to make it spelled out
um you're talking about polynomials mod
two yes yes sorry yeah developments so
yeah motto
yeah all right thank you Russell yeah so
Justin actually you can phrase these
things also for two and in fact uh by
the way Russell uh I think a question
that I like very much uh this thing here
is surprisingly is even open for a real
values polynomials where any non-bullion
uh output counts in your favor as a
mistake
okay so even giving a polynomial even
giving a function that cannot be uh
cannot that's not a description with the
real value polynomials if you output 17
accounts as a mistake the evidence is
open
and a candidate for that is parody
but we don't know how to how to prove it
but but for now so after this
parenthetic remark uh for now you you
can think of multiple polynomials
the connections from from before and
foreign but this question here is even
open for real I think it's really I
think it's interesting question so it's
kind of like it's the polynomial analog
of the rigidity question because the
rigidity over real so you can think of
it as the relative question
but okay so for now let's just think of
Motu so it's known that for the majority
function
you can pick a uniform distribution and
you have this bound of the arrow will be
D over root n okay so this is a great it
handles very large degrees of polynomial
degrees right but the error is not that
good right it's just one over then at
best on the other hand of the spectrum
uh you know this this fascinating work
by by Nissan which introduced this
iterated cautious words
technique in the field that they proved
for different functions like digitalize
in the product or the motri functions
um
that you can get the error which is
exponentially smaller in N over 13 so
this is like fantastic when this time
you get expenses more and it does
nothing when these like login
okay so in particular one setting which
is not which is covered by the result is
this uh
uh Epsilon 1 over 10 give me a give me
error one over then and for the slogan
okay this thing is not no work like this
thing it doesn't give you a good enough
energy this thing does does not give you
a good enough
and interestingly uh this setting here
this one here is formally required for
progress on any of the problems in the
blue slide so if I go back here
so you know Valance problems the more
than the polo players in Multiverse
communication Progressive definitely
conjectures quasi-position they will
require you to solve this
um yeah so
that's the set of offers
any questions up to now
okay uh so this was uh introduction
again I'm going to mention some a couple
of recent results on
correlation bounds
and yeah
and then we'll go to some
some random generators and some recent
results
uh so the one thing that I want to start
with uh is this nice work by these
people here
um appear just a couple of years ago
they
they defined the notion of local
correlation
okay uh so if you have a function
now it's not working if you have a
function and if you have a subset of the
variables you look at what happens when
you uh pick a random and the values
outside of the set s of of variables and
you look at the variance of what's left
okay or the variance are just over the
variables in s okay and they prove this
this nice thing that
um if you have a polynomial f
um this local correlation is small
and you can find for a set as of
variables which the size only quote
unquote only of size exponential in the
degree
okay so this is like nice when we when
degree is more when degrees smaller they
use this to obtain a new collection
bounds which we don't know how to prove
otherwise as far as
but it doesn't
or just a small question is is the
square inside the bracket instead of uh
this this is work with Ivanova is a PhD
student
part of which was at the time in
undergraded he's now a PhD student as
well we give a counter example to this
conjecture in fact we will out even a
weak form they actually conjecture
something much stronger but without like
even a weak form we showed what they
prove is the best possible essentially
and the proof uh is you know I guess
catch it now
uh
so you can start with the tribes enf
this is you know it's a standard uh
extreme example in in the analysis of
Boolean functions like it's just it's a
node of ends
uh
okay now it does interesting properties
and it can be shown
that
um
this this function has some good
properties can extract or like
properties on one side so in particular
um if you set the variables outside of S
and S can be as large as about and
overall again then then that's enough to
force the function to be one with
constant probability okay so just just
setting the values
so you have like a pretty large set s if
you if you set the variable of service
uniformly that's enough to force the
function to be caused to be one with
constant probability
okay and then if you think about the
the local calculation has to be large
because the expectation of the tribes is
uh about zero is the balance function so
this reputation over excess here has to
compensate for this constant here so it
has to be pretty different from zero so
we have local you have large local
coalition
and okay it's it's again if it's not the
polynomial but the thing is that you can
approximate it by low degree phenomenal
uh like kind of like the raspber of way
um and you can prove that this this
approximation actually would preserve
this large logar correlation so you can
approximate it by a login degree
polynomial and you still have a large
local correlation
uh so this is a counter example
um well additional any any questions
yeah so I know this maybe should
the biggest thing then maybe we need you
know some new approaches and in fact
um
there's even some barriers for proving
correlation bounds that there's like a
nice work
um about uh non-classical polynomials
being a barrier
um and so you know this is a better
which is specific to polynomials
so we should maybe think of some other
approaches so in in his work we propose
some one such
such approaches so so we make a you know
conjecture which is maybe bold but uh
it's plausible uh as far as I know
so we congested that
um
uh you know if you look at functions
like mod 3
um the polynomial 2 which maximize the
correlation are asymmetric
when I say maximize the relation I I
don't mean
almost optimal I mean exactly
so it means right here exactly so these
are the the exact maximizer that you're
gonna do anything better than
that this is somewhat strange preps
because in other settings uh similarly
parameters are known to not be
optimal but in this setting which will
be important we congested that they are
okay and if it was the case this would
this would imply Some Dream Collection
bounds because it's known that metric
polynomial is a very small correlation
with the battery
functions uh I'm going to make a couple
of comments on this conjecture so one is
that the
distinguish it uh seems to bypass these
barriers that are just mentioned
um uh in particular you wouldn't need to
distinguish between a classical and
non-classical polynomials as far as we
know so
the better the dimension does not seem
to apply and also
uh we actually have
you know the conjecture is not just for
motri and our results are not just
format three but more generally
for this phase functions uh so you can
take any complex number Z and you can
raise it to the the sum of the excise uh
so so Z just any complex number on the
unit circle uh so so motris is a special
case of this but we conjecture this for
any such
function and we actually we we prove it
in the case of degree two so it may
result in this work is that we can prove
this one direction for the re to
polynomials so the exact maximizers of
the relation with material with any
function of this type for any Z so even
mod 5 and moppy anything else are
quadratic symmetric
and this is you know is done by a
technique which doesn't seem to to have
appeared earlier so we we kind of like
write down the correlation in terms of
derivatives
and then we kind of like open open one
bit of the derivative at the time and
each bit that the European should be
that you that you fix we connect it to
the the corresponding derivative foreign
match
the symmetric
um derivatives to the derivatives of any
quadratic polynomial
so I'm not gonna see more about this
proofing because I want to discuss other
things
and but the case of degree 3 is
absorbent uh it's only known for some
special classes
mod degree three I think it would be
nice to prove it for a degree three but
it's not canon any kidney questions
okay
uh okay so I want to move
to a little bit other things I want to
talk about
pseudonym generators and some
some results
so okay
so it's random generous you all know
what they are so I'm not going to Define
them again uh I want to make a couple of
comments that they're known to be
equivalent to correlation bounce
if the error is more
okay so if you give me a prg which has
very similar or Epsilon this implies a
correlation bounds with about the the
same Epsilon
and around it's known if the correlation
bond is proven that the the uniform
distribution this will be a Nissan's
famous you know design construction if I
give you a collection bound with very
similar for the uniform distribution you
can construct a plg
um I don't know what happens for large
errors so conceivably you can have a
generator which has constant error and
um being completely unrelated to
correlation bounds for small error I
only know about the one work which
connects the two but it's only for a
special class of vegetables like uh yeah
so
I think it's it's interesting question
to try to to relate
what happens like prgs with constant
error and correlation bounds for small
error but I don't
I don't know how to
to to do it
okay
so
uh this through the art uh for phds for
polynomials is in this series
who works and you know the the Paradigm
is in this work with Andre
bogdanova that says that if you want to
fool a degree the polynomials uh the way
that you can do it is to you take the
independent copies of jetters for degree
one
promise and you just use some of them
together okay so it's it's a very simple
Paradigm you just take the copies of
generals for a degree one you sum them
and this actually criminalized the four
degree is more constant time so again
but beyond that is unknown
um so it's conceivable that this thing
works for any degree like a degree end
to adaption and again it would be you
know a predict result and but nobody can
prove it or or give a counter example
and I'm going to discuss this thing
later
um
because of some of some recent worker
but now I'm going to talk about this
Fourier conjectures which I mentioned
earlier
so to try to improve
uh this uh performance in other settings
there's been some new paradigms being
proposed uh that are called the the
polarizing random works
um and basically it's a way to construct
the prgs as random generous from and
from free bounds so in an effort to get
better results for polynomials uh some
specific Fourier conjectures were put
forth uh for the free spectrum of
polynomials
um so in particular it was conjecture
that if you have a polynomial P of the
of DVD if you sum
coefficients of size 2
then you you you you get a bound which
is only quadratic in the degree of the
foreign okay well it actually further
functions like majority can get much
bigger it can be like in like Ruden or
something
and uh
more generally it was congested that you
know if you look at the sum of the the
Fourier the Fourier coefficients of size
k
you get this bound here
um the second bound not so it's also
recorded by Lee who's who's very strong
exhibition student of mine is currently
on the job market so you should
interview him and hire him if you can
um
okay so these things were proposed and
so ethereum that we proved is that
uh this conjecture in fact even weaker
ones uh they imply a new the implied
Collision bounds which solve the problem
in the pure slide they particularly beat
uh rasboros molensky lower bounds
um
and uh
the functions uh they will be harder for
for polynomials are some variants of
majority they are kind of like
polynomial threshold functions
okay so even proving these things so it
was all clear at the beginning that you
would need correlation balance for this
approach
also some of these things some of these
things only give prgs with the constant
errors it was not clear that that the
name that they implied
uh correlation bounce uh via the
previous connections but we had this new
connection uh you can show that they
still require Collision balance
uh any questions on this
so I'm not going to say much about this
proof because I want to talk about other
things but
uh it's not it's not hard it's like half
a page
um but because of this uh we gave some
more thought about uh
correlation bounds for a majority so I
want to discuss this a little bit so
you know one approach now to refute in
these conjectures would be to just
give Coalition upper bounds for these
things like maybe these things are
actually easy to correct with and then
the conjectures before so we tried
through that so we aim to resolve these
conjectures but we we didn't merge uh
still we
we we discovered just some things that I
want to tell you about so one thing that
I want to emphasize which I think is
nice problem is that the decoration with
majority is open
so we don't know uh this was it was
somewhat
um surprising to me I I it was not clear
in my head but this thing is not known
so smonesky proved that this band which
I mentioned earlier of the D over Ruden
fantastic for majority and this thing
can be shown to be tight best possible
bound under the uniform distribution
okay you have polynomials which have
this correlation with majority and the
uniform distribution okay it's not
immediate but you can polynomials that
do that
but it's only under the uniform now what
happens under what is like a worst case
distribution how bad can can this thing
be
does anyone have any guess the size
let's say yes so there will be the
distribution do you think it will be
propound you think we can we can have
under every distribution will be uh I
think so any are you going to guess this
actually I don't know I mean it's still
open but some new bounds are
improved
I mean maybe it's still the overrated
it's not yeah
it's uh it's not so
um
so
this next claim doesn't does not refute
what you said but the one at the bottom
does so
it can be shown
um that um
you can have polynomials which have
correlation quadratic in in this so This
Square Over N under every distribution
okay so this is a prop this is a
construction of polynomials
which have correlation
the square of this is kind of like a
weaker in terms of bounds but it works
on the average distribution for every
distribution I can give you a polynomial
which has correlation D Squared Over N
which is the square of smallest skin
bound and I can just
that this thing is tight this is this I
think is a tight Bound for polynomials
and I don't know how to prove it but it
can be shown in the simple case of the
rig one okay this seems like
uh simple like it just didn't want to
just linear polynomials but
it looks real and maybe it is but
observe that
this already requires you to go beyond
the uniform distributions right because
for uniform distribution the rebound
will be one over n
okay and here actually you get one over
n
you get like a stronger bound here for
dd1 so this actually uh so what raster
was saying the operating is not correct
because for the one you get a 1 over 10
actually the bound is one over n and and
again yes the distribution here uh they
are distribution here will be like
you know you get
two I mean weights two slices and you
then and you can prove that it gives you
this bound so it seems realistic that
you know for larger degrees you can get
a bit more slices maybe you get these
slices okay and you get this bound here
but it gets kind of Technical and I I
was not able to
make much harder but I think it's
possible to to do it even like maybe at
least for cause and degree I think it's
nice question I I hope that I can
interest some of it seems like it really
to me like a basic question about
majority
and polynomials
um but that's the the zero affairs
any
questions
okay uh so that's the thing okay so now
um
I want to uh talk about the recent
results uh about
a new approach to construct
random generators
um
using invariant Theory and other things
um yeah so let's let's move to that and
let's see how
let's see what do we get so
um identifying 200 years until I'm going
to do Define them now because we're
gonna have to play with the field size
so I want to make sure that that
everybody is on board with different
fields so just to be precise
foreign
the seed rent is accessed to a tuple of
n Filled elements
and and I'm working over a generic final
field F okay and I clean it I can see
that that this thing fools degree the
polynomials in and variable C Force if
the statistical distance
between the Apple distribution of the
polynomial over uniform inputs is closed
um
to the right the statistical distance
between the povu right is
uh and the output distribution of the
polynomial when you plug the output of
the generator is small okay so these are
distributions of ref
the field so they're not just bits like
not just look at what's probably
adopting one I have to look at the whole
distribution and the field is going to
be large now exactly you know I want to
have that the the statistical distance
is small we're going to be able to
achieve that
you you would think of weaker Notions
like
maybe like
hitting the zeros but this is uh
we're gonna be able to achieve this
okay so this is our notion
and
the the electricity two lines of works
on this and one is the case of small
fields and everything I was mentioning
until now essentially accepted for its
Mori Market is for a small field like
zero one okay like mod 2. and this
started you know with this uh you know
Landmark paper by now and now in the 90s
which they do it this is the small bias
generosity which does it for degree one
uh which has you know like a immediate
applications and then the case of large
degree as I mentioned earlier is this
this work with the boy turn off
and we have this Paradigm which we
introduced that if you want to follow 3D
you take the copies of the generator uh
for degree one and you judges you just
sound okay so it's very simple
Construction
and it can be analyzed uh in the Citroen
this login plus exponential in B so this
as I mentioned earlier doesn't do
anything for degree larger than clogen
and it's slogan problem like this is
like there could be a counter example I
spent like
a long time trying to come up with a
counter example for large D and a field
uh so maybe there isn't a counter
example you know I would be very happy
to do that
and then there's actually another lines
another line of work leadership which
predates uh
this Paradigm which is the case of large
fields and here there is a very nice
paper by uh Bogner by Andre
um
uh whom we just saw in the Pure Stock
which goes to a completely different
route and
it reduces the question of constructing
agitators to a heating set so in which
you don't want to you just want to hit a
polynomial
uh okay so I'm not going to discuss this
in detail but then after this um
motivated by this there was like a
series of
constructions of heating sets for
polynomials which now are known of with
optimal parameters so now we know that
the best possible heat inside that you
might want to plug in this specific uh
connection and if you use them you get a
seed length for prolonged for uh jadors
of this type it's the power of d d to
the four log n plus log the field size
okay if the field is is large enough
okay so a drawback of these things is
that the dependence of the in this the
seed length uh you know is not uh
terribly good you know it's D to the
power of four well the right dependence
is just D okay uh and in fact it can be
shown and we argue in our work later uh
that this approach cannot give you seed
length even less than this Square okay
so it's like there's like a bottleneck
in this reduction
um
that prevents you from getting like
close to B but the more interesting I
think
these two approaches were completely
different like this uh you you some
degree one thing so you have this
heating set it's a complete completely
different approaches
um
and uh yeah
so go ahead
where is silly question on the small
Field construction uh if you only sum up
degenerators why do you need due to DC
lens is it because of the error yeah
thanks yes yes so yeah so there you go
from Arrow episodes
for every time that that you apply this
so that's uh that's the problem uh and I
think actually a fantastic question uh
in my opinion uh
uh I'm sorry
um I'm totally biased I shouldn't say
fantastic but anyway but something that
I spent a lot of time is this right I
mean let's just say that that you go
from degree one to degree two
okay so although we know how to do is
this loss here the square root loss to
me is this inherent to full degree to
polynomial like forget to go into degree
like login or Beyond just from degree 1
to degree two can you save this square
root
um I've really really love to see an
answer to the question
but uh
uh is not not
okay so uh these two lines that follow
different paradigms
um and so I want to talk now about this
work with the Dirksen uh
he's a mathematician
um
so we were able actually to to analyze
uh this program Viola paradigm for large
degrees
so this is good it's what we want but
only of course the catch usually it only
we can analyze it for our large fields
okay but we can analyze what happens
when you sum we use some generators for
degree one
even over over large degrees
if the field is large enough in the
draft and using this we can get new
generators uh over large Fields okay so
in particular
we are able to get Optimus hit length
which is a d log n plus log this at the
size of the field this is the optimal
dependence up to constant in front if
the if the field is large enough so the
field
has to have you know
size d to the power four times some
power in N the number of variables okay
uh if you want to to reduce the
dependence on on Nano you can make it
uh Power of the log
of of n so that's that's much better and
you get almost optimal you get like uh
nearly optimal let's see them so you're
gonna have some log logs here hit the
list
I know if you really
you know stingy with Urena you want like
no dependence on end then we can match
the the previous best that that we had
in terms of strength the ones that comes
from the boiling thing but we also
require
field size uh D to the power four while
the previous work had to to the power
six okay now maybe not I mean who cares
you know it's just four six you know I
mean three four five I mean who cares
well actually there is a point that uh
four is the right constant because it's
the best possible that you can get with
Veil bound okay so all this works with
large degrees and large field they
already
um on Veil bound from algebraic geometry
box required we required it and that
bound is only applicable when the field
size is the fourth power of the okay so
the bound
is you know
um the Filas will be quadratic in the
genus or the surface and the surface of
a polynomial degrees which is quadratic
in the there is you get F power four
so if you want to improve this power for
you you have to uh go beyond the felt
bound which in you know which is it uh
seems like a challenge uh so yeah this
is like the best that that you can get
if you want to use a felt bounce
okay uh so uh I'm kind of I'm kind of
happy because I I uh ask you for a 50
more minutes and I think actually I'm
going to use it I was worried like just
using below or let's type but yeah so I
want to try to give you some some ideas
of how this proof Works uh because you
use this Maria has some concept which
you were not used in this data before so
maybe they can be used for something
else
okay
Okay so
uh because for now is there any question
on the statements before we get into the
proof
okay
uh okay so
um I want to give you an overview of
truth I want to expose you to to some
Concepts which uh
I don't know about and you know I see I
felt like that I was I was learning
something whatever I was doing it so I
think uh I think maybe it's good to
review them so
uh one notion that we that we use is
that of decomposability of polynomials
so and this
uh so I'm gonna say that the polynomial
of G
over some field is decomposable
if first if you write G
as the composition of a univariate
polynomial C with a multivariate
polynomial H for some University of
degree be bigger than 2. okay so for
example
okay if I have you know if my G is you
know the sum of the X size Square
okay this thing is obviously
decomposable this is maybe the simplest
example we can actually see what you're
writing oh where your face is
oh my okay can write on on the left
over here the upper left corner should
be fine yeah thank you okay but thank
you for uh telling me how do you know
that my face uh okay so if G is the sum
of the excise
Square
um right this may be simple as possible
example this thing is decomposable so I
can take C my univariate program I just
x square
okay and H will be just the sum of the X
dice
okay so this is so this implies that the
G is
decomposable
okay you can think of other examples of
course but this is simply so so C is a
universe polynomial
okay so you decompose is this and a
dilemma uh that we
we prove it by putting together some
results in algebraic geometry
um
is this one here which you know it's
important for his work that if you have
any polymer G which is
um
in the component that cannot be
decomposed
so it's it's you know it's it's
registering that cannot be decomposed in
the composable then in fact the output
distribution of G over uniform
is close to uniform right in this
example here with the square the
distribution will not be uniform
right because it's just going to be a
square so it's it's very different from
uh uniform distribution just so you know
from Over the square shift if if if the
field that's like you know it's Prime
will just be squares
um so if the problem is not decomposable
then you have the guarantee somewhat
magically that if you plug uniform
values for the variables then you see
what problem spits out is going to be
close to uniform okay so this looks
powerful
um
and so
the main Lemma that we show is not this
is this one that comes here
the middle Emma that we show is the
construction of polynomials F1 F2 FN
which has some nice
properties the main important properties
for us is that they Preserve in the
composability
okay so if if you if you have a
polynomial age and you plug these F's
for the variables
if this composting is decomposable then
in fact even the original polynomial in
the excess was decomposable okay so The
Preserve in the composability
okay and the polynomials also needs to
have you know a few variables and have
low degree okay because you're going to
pay all these things in the in the seed
length but the the Key properties this
this the the that they Preserve in the
composibility
and uh okay so once this now I can give
you the generator I can tell you so let
me sketch the general so my my generator
would just be left okay so you take a
bunch of of random values for the
variables in your output you them to the
F so that you know it's F1 F2 a fan of
this thing okay so the first output
variable for the generator is just F1 of
the U the second will be f2w and so you
have n variables that you compute from a
small CDU which is only a handful of
variables so let me now sketch you how
you put all these things set together to
prove that that the distinct full
Elemental let's say that you want a full
sample MLG okay
so you have some G you want to fool it
with this F's okay so how do I
accomplish that so my first step is that
I'm going to write G as a c composer
with h
where C now is a is a universe
polynomial of Maximum degree
okay so I pick a universal maximum
degree and write the gsch and a critical
observation is that this H here is in
the composable
this H here is in the composer can
someone tell me why that's the case
okay can someone follow this
what happens if you could decompose h
what's that
month's degree exactly exactly thank you
right so if H could be decomposed as far
then in fact a c would not be a maximum
three
right so I I would like compose who
compose a piece of H in C so because I
pick C or maximum B this h a is in the
compostable but now I'm gonna apply this
line here so if you if you if you think
of g u i can write the G as a c h u
right this is just a g just value but
because h of U because H is
indecomposable by by dremma each of you
has the same distribution as just you
it's just a uniform
okay this is like a key step
okay and because they have serve in
noticeability even the H of the F's is
in the composite in the composer so I
can also write U as h of the F's
right because of this Lemma again
okay and you know C of DH of the F's is
just my G
on my generator
right and so that that's what I want to
do so that g of DFS has the same
distribution as your view
okay this this U here is a much fewer
variables than than this U here this is
what I'm getting in inside
that's
uh yeah yeah go ahead
so uh we're we're in the proof to use f
is large I guess both dilemma and the
main level yes so uh in actually yeah
actually in both places uh so no no
um so not to commented if I mean on that
uh this thing
um we give several versions of this and
in fact we can prove this even over uh
F2 so we're gonna start yeah if you just
want to preserve this it only shows up
here
the the large f is only for this step
here this is where I use a fill bound
and I guess the distance between gu and
the uniform distribution depends on the
cell side
yeah I mean
uh
yeah you cannot prove anything if the
field is small I mean yeah you cannot I
mean yeah you will have like a distance
like one or something oh thanks
thanks cool okay no thank you
okay so
um
I need to define the F's so I want to
Define these F's okay in fact the the
definition is uh simple
um so I want to give you like one minute
definition so you can start with um
uh yeah you can start with any
collection of
monomials
in some M variables of degree K so just
just forget everything you have M
variables you just look at all possible
monomials of some degree in those
variables okay
and then just like you know in the
Paradigm from before if you want a full
degree the polynomials you might take D
copies of the variables so if you have
if you have a variable X I'm going to
have variables you know X1 variables
copy X2 and so on so in the superscript
I have which copy of the variables you
can think of the variables as being in
in Matrix you have uh d d copies and
my fi which was the ith output of my
generator
is you take the ice monomial and you sum
it over any possible copy of the
variable okay so if your monomial was
like uh you know it was like you know x
y
uh then you know F would be uh you know
X Y with respect to the first copy plus
X Y with respect to the second copy
and so on okay
so you take any monomial and you just
sum it already copies and this is like
it's an algebraic
version of this Paradigm of summing over
different copies
um if also because you don't you you
don't have to take environments you can
take in fact you can start with any mice
which Full degree degree one polynomials
you can prove that you take copies of
that and and and this would be good
enough definition of the of the FI okay
so
um okay
so I want to spend just a minute
where the uh the invariant Theory shows
up because I think this shows how you
exploited this um
this said that that you take Hobbies um
so
our goal is to show that this this
advice preserve uh in the composibility
so I want to show that if you have a
polynomial
GLG and you plug my FIS which I Define
earlier that just is some monomials over
copies of variables if you could
decompose this which means I grad it as
a c
composed with some H in the axis
okay then in fact even the original
polynomial G just in the axis can be
decomposed as something else you see of
Leverage okay this is my goal
okay I'm sure that this file is
preserved in the accessibility and I I
just want to flash the key steps of this
to show you where the invariant theory
uh comes up because you know it seems
that it could be useful
in this area so uh
so the critical observation is that uh
this polymer here literally composer
with f is invariant and we're premiering
the copies of the of the variables this
is for three reasons because my files
if I permute the copies they will not
change because they are defined as the
sum of the copies and so even this
problem here the composition of geodfc
is invalented so if you permute the
copies of the variables
you don't change the the polynomial so
using this you can show that if you
could decompose it even this polynomial
here would be invariance and the
premiered in the the copies this is like
a step
and
um
it can also be shown that this files
that I pick are a basis for the
invariant polynomials so because my age
is invariant I can write h
is it is a polynomial of these F's okay
so this polynomial signature day curve
is they can express any possible
invariant polynomial the basis for the
invariant ring of polynomials okay so
you can write H because H is invariant H
is next so I I write it as a as a
polynomial a little H in the in DFS
um and from this You can conclude
using the structure of the F's that uh G
self can be decomposed okay I'm not
gonna
see more because I think it's again late
but the key thing that I want to
emphasize is that because of the
structure of the the generator
permutation so
um if you can decompose uh into CH you
don't write H also H is is a invariant
and you can write it as a polynomial in
in DFS and then you can conclude that
the original age
the surgery was also invalent
okay so I'm going to uh
move on unless the question
um just want to mention like super
quickly uh we actually give several
different analysis of this of this idea
um one the simplest one is actually it's
not hard at all uh it's just you know
maybe two two pages it's very Elementary
mathy as I think it's fairly accessible
like you and to me uh there's not too
much
it doesn't quite give the best possible
parameters but uh you know it still
gives some good parameters the most
advanced version It's Complicated uh but
but using that we can get the best
possible parameters and we can also as
uh the previous question we get we can
get it to work over over any field so if
you just want to preserve in the
composibility you can also do it over
over over F2
uh so the only constraint on the field
size now is from a bail bond
okay uh last comment on this this is all
all this stuff that I said actually
uh doesn't quite give the optimal
dependency because if you think of that
I'm still plugging field values for the
variables of deployment so it will still
give a multiplicative dependence on on
the field size like no matter what I do
because you have field elements
but in fact the rights dependence is
additive
and uh to achieve this actually you need
one more step you actually we combine
this stuff that I just discussed with
the with the variant of boctangle
generator based on the heating set and
that HCL that actually allows us to
decouple you know to have a negative
dependence on the on the field size okay
so I think I'm gonna
I want to thank you very much again for
listening for the opportunity of
speaking here
um
thank you
you can just pick up those microphones
should be able to pick up
performance
solutions to conjecture
okay thank you so much
thank you
so we have about 10-15 minutes till next
stock